I was sleeping until 11 wake up for a
quick lunch and then keep sleeping or
take a nap so then I can recover from
the previous week and have enough energy
for the week after I also remember that
I hated hated hated Monday morning I
mean this is probably just too right
especially for these large strategy
consulting firms BCG Bane and so on I
mean you will just need to work quite
late you will often have these weekends
where you just sleep because you need to
recover from the week I mean frankly I
think Monday Tuesday Wednesday are
probably the hardest days you will wake
up often at 4 AM 5 AM to get to the
airport get the first flight out then
Monday evening Tuesday evening Wednesday
evening is going to be quite late hours